[Musique]
la légendaire cité perdue il faut qu'on
ait sauvé mes parents allaient babouche
bien sûr qu'elle connaît le petit singe
normal la jungle est parfaitement sûr on
ne voit pas ça tous les jours tu as par
terre ferme
nous aimons à mingora et la cité
thermale au cinéma le 14 août la
légendaire cité perdue
il faut la trouver avancé brut j'ai vu
un certain nombre de films qui se
passent dans l'agenda officiel le film
mais il n'y a aucune raison d'avoir peur
il ya juste quelques règles à suivre
pour nous il venimeuse doré
c'est super gênant un adulte qui
pleurent doha et la cité perdue
on a fait une grande découverte dans une
cité d'or antique on va enfreindre
quelques rêves percer le mystère si
l'énigme inca et découvrez la légende et
la cité perdue on va mourir ici au pour
quand même pas exagérer
au cinéma le 14 mai à doha et la cité
perdue
[Musique]
allons-y je tiens de la jungle
il n'y a aucune raison d'avoir peur si
on touche à rien on va tous mourir ici
on a fait une grande découverte dans une
cité d'or antique
par ap atteint les cimes rcnm la cers je
veux cette carte il faut absolument
arriver à vendre aux faut quand même pas
exagérer
c'est super gênant un adulte qui pleure
on sait jamais trop où regarder
[Musique]
la porte se referme ses pairs baddou sac
faut que j'arrête d'être surprise par
les trucs que tu sors de ton sac à dos
on s'enlise ok pas de panique
excusez moi
[Musique]